there's a photo on Twitter which caught
Donald Trump's son Eric in the act of
drinking lemonade at an in-and-out
burger a fast-food chain called
in-and-out burger which is in part of
the country now you might say David why
is that a big deal
of drinking lemonade at a fast-food
place that's really not a big deal well
the reason it's a big deal is because
Eric Trump was drinking lemonade out of
a free water cup this is when after the
third debate Eric Trump and his wife
Lara visited an in-and-out birder
location after that presidential debate
and David Winckelmann who's a friend of
another person who posed for a picture
with Eric Trump noticed that the cup
Eric Trump is holding in the tweet that
we're actually going to show you here is
a clear cup yet there is a yellow liquid
inside of it now for comparison here is
Eric Trump's wife with the actual cup
that in and out burger sells when you
have purchased a soda it's a different
cup it's abundantly clear there's this
is common at restaurants right there's a
particular Mexican restaurant that I go
to in Northampton Massachusetts that I
like which they have a bunch of plastic
cups and if you don't buy a soda it's
sort of on the honor system you can grab
a plastic cup and you go over to the
soda machine but you're supposed to only
put water there's one nozzle for water
in your cup and if you buy a soda it's
the exact same process you grab the
clear plastic cup you bring it over but
you can have whatever soda or lemonade
or whatever you want it's the honor
system and many times it crosses my mind
you know anybody could just grab a cup
and fill it with whatever you want but I
would never do that not only do I not
drink soda but if I wanted a soda I
would pay for the soda and I'm not a
multimillionaire or possibly billionaire
like Eric Trump now what would he say
about this would he say oh this makes
him smart pay for lemonade wrong Hilary
was a senator for years never passed a
law to change it her fault
Eric Trump is taking advantage of the
fact that you can just go up and get
lemonade even though you've got a free
water cup this is not about the dollar
or the two dollars this is about
privilege and this is about entitlement
Eric Trump's grandfather didn't get rich
by paying for things
his dad Donald Trump didn't get rich by
paying for things and he's just
following their lead and by the way in
April a man was actually charged with
robbery for pouring soda from McDonald's
into one of these free water cups you
got to stay rich somehow Pat yes there's
a few takeaways you could take from here
yeah
one he's not as rich and his family is
not as rich as they say they are and
they never at the oldest oh yeah right
or he's just out of touch and doesn't
really understand the etiquette that
goes on at these kind of fast-food
joints yeah or he's just being a jackass
when life hands you
millions of lemons you don't make
lemonade you steal it from in-n-out
burger reasonable people realize of
course that in the grand scheme of
things
Eric Trump stealing lemonade is nothing
compared to what Donald Trump would do
to this country as president the reason
it's relevant is it shows Eric Trump's
character which of course is heavily
influenced by his father's character the
Trump kids are millionaires
Eric Trump refuses to pay even a couple
dollars for lemonade it's a metaphor for
the entire family take advantage of
anybody you can take what you want
whether it's [ __ ] grabbing or whether
it's lemonade in a free water cup at
in-n-out burger I would never do this
would you ever steal the lemonade if you
would just pay for it wouldn't you or
have one yeah I'm not once to pay the
extra two three dollars for a soda I
have water with my meal water the
healthy option I agree with you Pat
absolutely spot-on